là parmi ces trois éventualités pour
l'avenir laquelle choisissez vous faire
fortune devenir un personnage connu
avoir du temps pour vivre agréablement
avec votre famille avoir du temps pour
vivre agréablement et pas forcément avec
ma famille à moi j'aimerais avoir une
immense fortune et qu'il va bien en
france qu est-ce qui veut bien en france
ça c'est dur
qu'est ce qui va mal en france a
beaucoup de choses et livré volts plus
ce qui me révolte le plus c'est le le
mépris général que font les que qu'ont
les autorités en général qu'elle soit
politique ou pas de de l'opinion et de
l'aider désir d de l'ensemble des des
personnes vous important dans la vie
c'est quoi l'important dans la vie c'est
la santé j'aimerais bien avoir du temps
pour vivre agréablement et d'autre part
je crois que j'aimerais devenir un
personnage connu connu même pas la
célébrité mais peut-être disons
populaire enfin aimé du mois
que les gens apprécient ce que ce que je
fais comment serez vous dans vingt ans
j'en sais rien
et qui vont alors elle te plus alors ce
qui me révolte le plus c'est le lycée
toute façon c'est le lycée je crois que
c'est le lycée qu'est-ce qui vaut aval
peu plus au passé c'est que les gens
entre nous il n'y a aucune pression
aucune solidarité entre les gens c'est
que c'est qu'il se regarde tout ça c'est
méprisant du fait que je n'ai que des
soufis d'autres pas alors on regarde les
gens par dessus l'épaule et puis il n'y
est pas y'a pas une existence vraiment
acceptable pour tous sur quoi il ya
quelque chose qui me révolte
à mon avis c'est quand même là la
différence qui existe entre les classes
sociales et le fait que par exemple les
ouvriers ils peuvent très difficilement
en sortir de justement de cette classe
ouvriére et et c'est aussi à un niveau
supérieur de mots on va beaucoup changer
[Musique]
pour vivre à ce sera beaucoup plus
moderne ou alors on aura retournement en
arrière je n'ose pas imaginer l'avenir
paraît bouché
l'avenir paraît bouché alors tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment le bon tu le vois
tu vois pas bien
ou parce que tel que c'est parti
maintenant avec toutes les crises
d'énergie quand on est en ce moment à
los détruit cinq à se reproduire tous
les ans appuyé les arnaques attendent
encore longtemps comme ça qu'il
s'améliorera point jamais leur tombera
un état de droit car il sera encore plus
visible pour toi qu'elle est votée par
an oui je pense parce que haïti avec
toutes tailles tous les problèmes qui
est maintenant et puis tout tracas comme
une folle
je pense que c'est s'améliorera pas que
ce soit beaucoup plus difficile
ça fait peur aura non pas tellement ça
viendra le clash la syrie tuera
progressivement
c'est sûr ça c'est plutôt peur comme ça
mais année quelle femme sera thürler
matin aucune idée alors là je ne sais
pas dit si je passe à ne pas savoir
comment tu verras oui mon singe suis pas
tellement d'idées sur ce sujet la 4e
je veux pas savoir comment je serai
heureux parce que si ça marche pour lui
de savoir mères de famille alors son
travail tous les jours
rentrant soir retrouvant sa famille
wenger c'est calme on reçoit quelques
aventures quand même pas toujours en fin
de quotidienne en battant ce serait pire
que maintenant laventure septembre
non c'est vrai du tout ta vie tu le vois
bien rangées bien se placer et de ce
fait comme ça c'est pas du talisman
en même temps je ne
[Musique]
je me verrais avec une famille une
profession
[Musique]
j'aimerais avoir des enfants je voudrais
plutôt consacrer à mes enfants
avoir un métier aussi mais être une
aventure partir comme ça c'est cool et
on peut tellement je préfère avoir pour
tendre avec les enfants mon mari à
bordeaux je comprends bien vous avez
presque tous déjà une sorte de devis
tracé dans la tête alors qu'il en a pour
qui voudrait qu'ils voudraient justement
vivre l'aventuré
sinon ça serait quoi cette voiture
dans
c'est un retournement des trucs comme ça
la vie rangée 3,7 soit pas varié je
prends pas soin pas d'enfant pourquoi
[Musique]